Harry Potter in the Church.
Needless to say,
spin rate. What have been
plucked out of warlocks
organized book burnings,
nationwide bands,
and I even heard a story of a child in
a Christian orphanage with nothing left
in the world,
but it's Harry Potter books who's forced
to burn them because they promoted
witchcraft. What is it about our own
imaginations that can be so terrifying?
I had a very active
imagination as a child.
I also happen to live in a
house with nine kids. They'll,
keeping track of me was impossible
one step outside and I was in another
universe,
so real and vivid that it was almost
indistinguishable from reality like mini
children. My imagination was easily
swept off into the world of fiction.
Naturally,
the stories I like best,
we're about knights and
quests and slaying dragons.
They were about King Arthur, Luke
Skywalker, and of course Harry Potter.
As soon as the new Harry Potter
book was available in the library,
it was a mad rush to be the first
one to check it out. Unfortunately,
I was told these books say tannic
witchcraft and I was never allowed to read
them.
Of course,
the fact that the books were forbidded
only made them that much more attractive.
I read them anyway,
hiding them all around the house and
getting caught all the time. Mr. Smith.
Oh yeah. Just masturbating. The books
clearly accomplished something amazing.
They had fifth graders reading five,
six and 700 page books and my own love
for reading to this day can be traced
back to that time in my life.
In my 11 year old mind.
I simply couldn't understand how something
which provided me with so much joy
and wonder could be evil.
I've come to believe that it is precisely
the amount of joy we received that
caused this kind of backlash
and it is not hard to see why.
What are we doing when
we get lost in a novel?
It is more than just
fantasy and escape isn't.
We are creating detailed
images in our mind,
bringing them to life and blurring
the lines between fantasy and reality.
That is magic. Like seriously
getting that immersed in something.
It's truly a religious experience and
unfortunately it's all too common.
The churches in the business of preventing
religious experience rather than
mediating it.
Look closely and you will see at its core,
the Harry Potter series is about a
religious transformation that's tyrannical
king becomes paranoid
about a new miracle child.
The child is then driven
out of the magical kingdom
only to return later as the
savior sound familiar.
Both were crucified for
telling people the truth.
They did not want to hear both willingly
face death to save the ones they love
and both died and were reborn. The story
of Harry Potter is his oldest time.
It is the endless battle
of good versus evil.
When Adam and eve ate of
the tree of knowledge,
the tension of opposites came into being
and it became apparent that the key to
heaven light and renouncing,
ignoring and suppressing our
most base in evil desires,
but that which we suppressed
does not simply go away.
Voldemort is a clear representation
of the young Ian Shadow.
Carl Young stated that
we all have a persona.
This is the mask that
we put on for the world.
It encompasses all those traits we
deem worthy and socially acceptable.
Then we have the shadow, the part of
ourselves. We hide from the world,
the basement of our psyche,
which stores every repressed memory
and every skeleton of our past.
These disowned parts of ourselves are
extremely valuable and cannot be discarded
without a cost.
If channeled properly,
they can fill our life
with meaning if ignored,
they will always find a way to express
themselves often in unforeseen and
destructive ways.
We all have a two sided nature.
Voldemort is the other side of Harry
and their lives aren't inescapably woven
together,
but it is emphasized time and again that
it was the choices Harry made that set
them apart. Voldemort is often
translated as flight from death.
That is what everyone does.
They refused to speak his name,
refuse to acknowledge
their own two sided nature,
refuse to see the darkness
that exists within themselves.
Everyone refuses to look except for Harry
in his first two encounters with the
pace of evil, he can only look at
it indirectly. First is reflection.
Then is nothing more
than a memory in a diary.
While he meets the face of evil
courageously, he's clearly outmatched.
This is a part of himself.
He does not yet understand
three words in the goblet
of fire change everything
up to this point.
These were child like adventure stories
where the hero always conquered.
This all changes. When Harry has his
first direct look into the face of evil,
he sees death, an experience
which changes him completely.
He now sees the world in a way his friends
cannot something which causes him to
question himself and his sanity,
but confrontation with the shadow was
actually what guides here. He's life.
He says, his aim to become an or and
to join the order of the Phoenix.
It provides his life with purpose and
meaning the strongest parts of himself.
His capacity for love and friendship
are discovered in his most vulnerable
moments.
Those who are reading Harry in the
Bible are experiencing the same thing.
There's a reason the death and rebirth
theme has survived in our storytelling
for thousands of years.
It speaks to something deeply
embedded within the human experience,
and it is the reason the story of a young
wizard has been able to successfully
reach the hearts and minds
of billions of people.